Jordan is a cat enthusiast she currently
cares for several cats but she just
can't say no to adopting another cute
little face after moving into a bigger
house Jordan started adopting cats at a
constant rate the number of cats in
Jordan's house see as a function of time
since she moved in days
t is plotted below so this Jordan she
just keeps adopting cat so her house is
just getting more and more and more full
of cats I guess it's got to stop at some
point but for this question they just
say she keeps adopting them at a
constant rate so let's look at the
choices here and see which of these
statements is true Jordan had ten cats
when she moved so let's see this is time
from when she moved in so time equals
zero is right when she moved in her
house and it does look like yes she had
ten cats right where she moved in so
that first part of the statement is true
and after moving she adopted two cats
each day so let's see the rate at which
she's adopting cats and I'm gonna find
another point on here so we know that
the point zero comma 10 is on here so on
day zero when time equals zero she
already had 10 cats which is seems to be
more than enough for for me but let's
see how many she gets two so all of
these other ones it's hard to read hard
to read well it looks like here this is
definitely on day 15 on day 15 she had
40 cats so let's see after 15 days when
her change in time her change in time
was 15 change in time is 15 what was the
change in her number of cats well she
went from 10 cats to 40 cats so she went
up to her change in the number of cats
and we could call that Delta C is equal
to she went from 10 to 40 her change in
cats is 30 so her change in cats over
change in time is 30 over 15 or you
could say to two cats per unit time per
day so it does look like she got two
cats per day after 15 days at two cats a
day she had 30 more cats she went from
10 to 40 so this statement looks right
this one is multiple choice so these
other ones
probably wrong but let's verify that
Jordan had three cats when she moved
well that's not true three would have
been right around here so that's not
right Jordan had ten cats when she moved
and after moving she adopted one cat
every two days one well that would be
half a cat a day and we know that that's
not the case you are she adopted two
cats a day after 15 days she had 30 cats
so this isn't right either Jordan had
three cats where she moved well we
already know that that's not the case so
we noticed the first choice